popularity of meal delivery kits is
growing in American kitchens these kits
contain pre-measured ingredients for a
variety of recipes they're delivered
straight to your door
Nestle the world's largest food company
just led a 77 million dollar funding
round for the meal delivery startup
freshly bad news came amid big
developments in the food business meal
kit company blue apron this week began
marketing its initial public offering
and the online giant Amazon is buying
Whole Foods Derrick Thompson is a senior
editor at the Atlantic Derrick good to
see you good to see you hi this is big
business know why it's interesting
because for a long time there wasn't
really a lot of innovation in food you
know for decades you could go to a
grocery store you go to a restaurant
that was basically it maybe you could
order pizza for delivery right now you
really have we're in a bit of a golden
age of food innovation right now where
people are realizing that you can take
the same principles of e-commerce that
worked for books that worked for clothes
and use them to deliver food to people
and that's really created this movement
where you have some of the biggest
companies in the world Nestle the
biggest food company in the world now
investing in this new era what's the key
to it I think one of the keys is
convenience I think you have a lot of
people who feel harried they want to
cook but they don't necessarily have
time or the wherewithal to go to Whole
Foods and buy the stuffs they order a
meal kit that brings it to them but in
many ways it continues this sort of long
historical line of convenience where
with books for example 1990s people said
who wants to buy books online bookstores
are where it's all at no it turns out we
want to buy books online same goes you
have clear those you that sure did yeah
that were the edge of this yes exactly
and now he's taking it on Whole Foods
yeah I just say to you I'm interested in
Whole Foods I think that Amazon wants to
put itself in Whole Foods and it wants
to put Whole Foods in Amazon boxes that
means that is to say animal son wants to
get into a brick-and-mortar retail
business they want to use whole food
stores to experiment with how people
move around to store buy their stuff
bundle items together but they also
maybe want to turn Whole Foods into a
delivery service itself so that you're
buying a book you're buying some clothes
you can maybe order some heirloom
tomatoes as well
what Hope Foods has there's a lot of
real estate locations has great real
estate real estate locations in urban
and suburban centers so basically even
if Whole Foods didn't sell food at all
Amazon could still use those stores that
that footprint as warehousing
to make sure that it's getting its
merchandise as close to its consumers as
possible now the Realtors say that if
there's a Whole Foods in the
neighborhood you're living in a really
good location but let's talk about those
startup those those meal kits because
the statistics show that most people
give it up within a year they order it
and they don't stick with it
so how sustainable is it this is the 1
billion 10 billion dollar question is
does the effort that it takes to market
the meal kits cost so much that there's
no way for any of these companies to
make money I would compare it a little
bit to the fast casual sector in food
that's the Chipotle's that sweet greens
fast casual locations have grown 9% over
the last year there's just an enormous
boom but as a result same store sales
are down 2% so you have this enormous
abundance of food options but as a
result no individual store is doing well
the same thing could happen for meal
kits so much competition that each
company individually struggles I tried
one of these for the first time last
week it was like a hybrid well I I mean
I still I messed it up but but it was
still better than it would have been if
I started from scratch I think I got
improvement as Lazar Alice half-full I
suppose so we do it again Jeff I think I
would you all right yeah so let's see
what let's talk to you in a year all
right here that is Thank You Derek thank
you always good to have you at the table